Welcome back, everyone.
It's Charlie. Huge Batman news.
James Gunn announced his plans
for the future of Batman in the DCU.
Connected movies, The Batman,
The Brave and the Bold
being the first time that he shows up.
And he confirmed that it would be
another Batman, not Ben Affleck's Batman.
But it sounds like, according to leakers,
it will be an older Batman
who's coming back from previous
Batman movies,
because James Gunn
also confirmed that it would not be Robert
Pattinson's Batman
because it was going to be a Damian
Wayne Bat-Family based movie
and to be an older version of Batman.
So we'll break it all down
if you're brand new to the channel.
Be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos.
We're still learning about all of these
new James Gunn rebooted DC movies.
It's still a developing situation.
We've also got a ton of Super Bowl
trailers coming this weekend.
The Flash movie is the big DC trailer
they're releasing.
There's a bunch of big Marvel trailers
too. Of course.
I will do videos for everything.
There's been a ton of news
about the new rebooted DC movies.
Superman Legacy is like
the first official big movie
with a recast version of Superman.
The Batman and Brave in The Bold movie
Sounds like it's not going to be released
till the year after that in 2026.
We know Henry Cavill will not be that new,
younger version of Superman,
but because the Batman, The Brave
and the bold
movie will be a Damian Wayne based movie,
it'll be an older Batman.
So Batman would have to be much older
than Superman in now.
The report, according to leakers,
is that it will be an older Batman
coming back that they're bringing back
from earlier Batman movies like not just a
totally new actor, but someone who played
Batman in previous movies.
As funny as that sounds, because that's
the whole twist with Michael Keaton
coming back in The Flash movie
as his Batman like the whole Twist
and Ezra miller Flash movie is him going
to Michael Keaton Batman's Earth
causing a version of Flashpoint
rebooting the DCU into James Gunn's DCU
with a couple of different actors
in a slightly different continuity,
like they're retuning the backstories
of some of the characters
so that everything makes sense
going forward.
The next ten years of DC movies
and they recast some of the actors
as part of that Batman being one of them.
Originally there were supposed to be
Henry Cavill, Superman, Gal Gadot,
Wonder Woman cameos in the movie
reportedly,
they took those out of the movie
because they were meant to set up
future movies
that they're not doing anymore.
Now they've also reportedly removed
Michael Keaton
from the end of the Flash movie.
And now the big twist at the end
will be this new DCU James Gunn, Batman
Brave in the bold version of Batman
to be in the movie,
setting up the new line of DCU movies.
If this is true,
I don't know what this new older Batman
cameo seen at the end of the movie
is going to look like,
or if his phaser voice
will be clearly identifiable, or
if it'll be like Henry Cavill's
Superman cameo in the first Shazam movie,
which was just his version of the suit,
and there weren't any lines of dialog.
The only way that you knew
was supposed to be him
was if you knew that it was the same
Superman suit design. But
in according to leakers.
Here's the thing
He's either supposed to be Val Kilmer
coming back as Batman from Batman forever.
George Clooney coming back from Batman
and Robin or Christian Bale
coming back from the Dark Knight trilogy
now, because we're talking about an older
Batman coming back from other movies.
Ben Affleck
also is an older Batman, technically,
but when James Gunn talked about him
being involved creatively in future
DC movies, he sounded like he was talking
about directing a future DC movie,
not being actual Batman.
Like the way he talked about it.
It would not be Ben Affleck,
Batman on screen.
So if these leakers are correct
with their reports
that they're bringing back
an older Batman,
and it's one of these three,
the reason why I think it would be
Christian Bale is because when Val Kilmer
can't speak, like literally
he can't talk.
The whole twist with him in Top Gun,
Maverick was a bit of a one off quick
thing.
He wouldn't come back for something
as big and demanding as this.
Like the new DCU, Batman
is going to be playing the character
for at least the next ten years.
There's also a couple
new Justice League team up movies
that they'll probably wind up doing too.
I also do not think that it's George
Clooney because he's almost as old
as Michael Keaton in reportedly
it will not be Michael Keaton to be Damian
Wayne's father. Is this new DCU Batman?
George Clooney made it sound like
he was never going to come back as Batman
after the debacle.
That was Batman and Robin.
But he does apologized profusely
and like Ryan Reynolds as Green Lantern,
he continues to make fun of himself
as the character.
Like, yes,
I also thought it was ridiculous
that we did nipples on the Batsuit.
He also probably doesn't want to sign up
for another ten years as Batman.
And I don't think James Gunn
wants to build an entire new universe
of continuity on top of the Batman
and Robin movie of all of them.
Christian Bale is probably
one of the best versions of Batman
we've had in the history of the character.
Some people still think
that he is the best.
The Christopher Nolan movies were
universally loved by fans and critics.
In the new movie is a Damian Wayne bat
family movie and in The Dark Knight Rises.
His Batman had a very quick,
albeit relationship with Talia Ghoul
before he gets stuck in the pit
for several months.
By the time Batman braving the Bull comes
out, he'd be in his early fifties,
meaning the timeline for when Damian Wayne
would have had to have been conceived
and brought to term would line up
between the way it happened in the comics
and in the movies.
So a lot of that backstory they already
did during The Dark Knight Rises.
And for those of you wondering about Talia
Al Gore at the end of that movie,
it seemed like she died. Now
it just seemed like she died.
But remember,
this is a comic book universe.
If you don't see the body
at the end of the movie,
that means that they're probably not dead.
And at the end of the movie, we only see
her slump over briefly sitting in the car
like Batman flies the reactor
away from the city before it explodes.
Then they have a big time
jump as he disappears, faking his death
and going to Europe,
where Alfred meets him,
where he's on holiday,
paying off his dream
for earlier in the movie when he said that
that was what he wanted for Bruce Wayne,
that he'd retire and go live a normal life
with the Joseph Gordon-Levitt
version of Robin becoming the new Batman.
Also, when James Gunn
was talking about Damian Wayne,
he referred to Grant Morrison because he's
the person who created the character
when they introduced him
in a big Batman title, Batman and Robin.
That was actually while Batman was gone
and Nightwing was wearing
the cape and cowl.
So was the Nightwing, Batman and Damian
Wayne together,
although that's probably not the way
they're going to do the Batman
and the Brave in the Bold movie.
But because the new movie is a Damian
Wayne based movie, he's about 14 years
old. When it picks up, that means Dick
Grayson has already become Nightwing.
He's already had Tim Drake.
We already have Red Hood.
So just from a continuity perspective,
there's just enough stuff
there in the Dark Knight trilogy
for this new Damian
Wayne Twist to make sense
in the new rebooted DCU.
And remember, we have Flashpoint so
they can always change a few minor things.
Also, during the Flash movie,
there was concept art when The Flash's
Crossing the Multiverse
that featured Christian Bale's Batman.
So like he is already in the Flash movie
in a way, so to speak.
But that was before
all the big changes and James
Gunn came on to reboot all the DC movies.
So they've already changed a little bit
about the Flash movie.
Just that all the reboots make sense
before this news
leaked out about an older Batman
coming back from earlier Batman movies.
I wouldn't have assumed
Christian Bale would come back
for like ten more years of Batman movies.
He has talked fondly about his time
as Batman with Christopher Nolan
and how they had originally discussed
doing a fourth Batman movie together
like a Fourth Dark Knight movie.
But originally, at the time
when they made The Dark Knight
Rises, Christian Bale
had said his attitude was that he wouldn't
make Dark Knight for unless Christopher
Nolan decided to actually make it.
In the last time
he was interviewed about it earlier
last year,
he was kind of noncommittal about it.
Like, you know, we talked about it,
but we made a pact that I wouldn't do
Dark Knight for without Christopher Nolan.
So it's not that
he didn't want to play Batman ever again.
Issues
that he was taking a knee for his friend.
And obviously we saw
how history played out.
Christopher Nolan moved on to Inception,
only staying on with DC to help produce
Zack Snyder's Man of Steel movie.
Then he helped advise them a little bit,
like he gave notes on Batman v
Superman and Justice League.
But he wasn't really involved creatively
with any future DC movies.
After Man of Steel.
Christian Bale
also just came back to big comic
book movies in Thor, Love and Thunder.
And even though I felt like they misused
the God of the God butcher character,
it sounds like a lot of his scenes
hit the cutting room floor,
because when they talk
about the deleted scenes,
it sounds like he went way more hardcore
than what wound up in the actual movie.
But usually when he talks about doing big
comic book movies,
he says he's up for doing more
if they're fun.
And a lot of times
the reason why actors as big
as him who could do any movie
they want to come back
to, big movies like this,
like Batman movies are doing other big
Marvel movies
is because they're kids are big fans.
This is what James Gunn said
about the Batman brave in the Bold movie
The introduction of the DC use
Batman is the Brave and the Bold.
The Brave and the Bold is the story of
Batman and his actual son, Damian Wayne.
This is based on Grant Morrison's
great comic book run.
Damian Wayne is my favorite Robin.
He's a little assassin
who Batman tries to get in line.
And so this is the story
of the two of them
and the beginning
of sort of the bat-family in the DCU.
Would that all means
is that the movie probably wouldn't
be as demanding on this older
version of Batman who winds up coming back
because you have this new Damian Wayne
actor in any of the other potential robins
that might be in the movie
or like Nightwing,
who might be in the movie,
also taking a lot
of the action of the movie.
So it's not like Batman on screen
all the time.
Hundred percent of the movie.
Christian Bale has talked a little bit
about Robert Pattinson's Batman.
He's been pretty optimistic about it.
Like, he was pretty happy
at the idea of Matt Reeves Batman movies
as far as everyone has said,
James Gunn and Matt Reeves,
those are going to be Elseworlds movies.
So like the Batman part
two will just continue
on doing its own thing.
The Batman HBO series with Penguin,
the other Batman spinoffs
are doing on HBO.
All going to be set in Elseworlds,
like I said, because Ben Affleck
has been talking
about coming back to DC movies, I think
it'll probably be to direct a DC movie,
so it is possible
we could have a new Batman Brave
in the Bold movie directed by Ben Affleck
and starring Christian Bale
or another older Batman coming back.
But if all the reports are true
and it is one of these older
versions of Batman coming back as Batman
in the new DCU movies,
which one do you think it's going to be?
It just feels like of all three of them,
Christian Bale makes the most sense.
Of course, I will do more videos
when we get more information about this.
This is like hot breaking news right now.
And the thing is, is that usually
when news is vastly incorrect,
a James Gunn will come out immediately
and tamp down on it like, hell
no, we're not doing that.
And he hasn't said anything about this
older Batman coming back
to be his new Batman in Brave in the Bold.
Usually when he's quiet on stuff,
it means there is kernels of truth in it.
Like I said, whole bunch of Super Bowl
trailers coming this weekend.
My video for the Flash movie
trailer will post soon
be sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss that.
Everyone click here for my other big flash
movie trailer video and click here
for my Ant-Man and the WASP Quantumania
video for Kang versus Thor and Loki.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.